teachers are you ready to get five hours
back this week kigo helps you develop
effective engaging and pedagogically
appropriate lesson plans in minutes so
you can spend more time teaching and
less time on everything else just click
the kigo icon on a piece of content that
you want to teach and see how kigo gets
to work co-developing a lesson plan with
your unique teaching style and class
needs Incorporated throughout
chat gpt's lesson plan on the same topic
is generic and nowhere near ready to
use so ready to level up your lesson
plans click the link in the description
below to get kigo now get kigo today and
get five hours back this
week